いらっしゃいませ。
彼氏：はぁ～。彼女：めっちゃおなかすいた。
彼氏：いや、めっちゃ腹へったな。彼女：ねぇーやばい、やばい。
彼氏：ねぇ、何食べる？彼女：うん、どうしようかな。
彼氏：ねぇ、何食べるか。彼女：何がいいよね。
彼女：・・・
二人：・・・
いらっしゃいませ。
お水です。
女子高生A：ねぇ、これを伝えたかったってさー、おかしくない？絶対。
女子高生B：もう自分に溺れすぎでしょこれ。
A：一人で何やってるのよって感じ。B：ヤバすぎる。気持ち悪い、キモい、キモい。
女子高生の話声
はじめん：すいませんがお客様が・・・
はじめん：お客様の迷惑になりますので・・・
A：ねぇ受けるよね。これゼッタイ！笑えなくない？絶対これ学ｋB：ヤバすぎる。
うるせぇ！
3人：・・・
はじめん：お会計が962円になります。
客：じゃあこれで。
はじめん：はい、ありがとうございます。1000円お預かり致します。
彼女：ねぇ、なに何してるの？彼氏：なにが？
彼女：それ見せてよ。彼氏：なにが、別にいいじゃん。
彼女：誰と連絡取ってるの?彼氏：なんでよ。別に誰だって良くない？友達、友達。
彼女：見せてよ、見せて。別に良くない？彼氏：なんで見せなきゃいけないだ。お前に？
彼女：だっていいじゃん。やましいことでもあるの？彼氏：なんでそこまで監視されなきゃやばいんだ。別にやましいことはないよ。
～喧嘩中～
はじめん：すいません。お客様、すいません。お客様の迷惑になりますので
うるせぇ！
3人：・・・
はじめん：あっあ、あ
はじめん：すいません。
大丈夫？
～片付け中～
バタン
！？
えっ
はじめん：大丈夫ですか？
おいどうした！？はじめん：大丈夫ですか！？✕2
お兄ちゃん、大丈夫か！？
店長！はじめん：大丈夫ですか！？
ちょっと救急車呼んで！　はじめん：救急車！はい、直ぐ呼んで、直ぐ呼んでください！お願いします！
大丈夫！？　大丈夫か？
おーい
ちょっと流血してるぞ。おい。
はじめん：誰かー！
A：最近さー、みんな、彼氏できちゃっているねー
A：みんな付き合い悪いよね、ホントに。
B；それな。
A：そういえばさー。Bうん。A：田中君とどうなったの？
B：それ、聞いちゃう？A：えーなになに？
B：実はね、一昨日付き合うことになって・・・
A：ホントに？B：うーん
A：良かったね。B：そう、なんかねOK貰えないと思ってたから・・・
A：えーじゃあラブラブだねー
奥様：ねぇねぇ。
奥様：付き合う？
B：え・・・奥様：田中君と付き合うの？A：知り合い？B：分からない。
奥様：ねぇーちょっと教えてよ。
客：じゃ、ご馳走様ー
はじめん：はい、ありがとうございまーす。
はじめん：はい、お会計が480円になります。
客：あっっ！
客：ごめんなさい。はじめん：大丈夫ですか。
客：あ、ごめんなさい。すいません。
うっ！ぬ！
うっう！
はじめん：大丈夫ですか？
客：ちょっと？
客：おじさん、大丈夫？
はじめん：大丈夫ですか？
客：大丈夫？
はじめん：おじさん！
客：どうした？どうした？
客：大丈夫すか？
はじめん：ちょっと、救急車をお願いします。
はじめん：おじさん！大丈夫ですか！？
客：もしもし？、もしもし？
はじめん：誰かー！
ーEDー